la cour du musée du compagnonnage c'est
un petit déménagement à l'abri de ce
carton à dessin des oeuvres datant du
19e siècle
des lithographies qui représente le
départ d'un compagnon du devoir pour une
autre étape de son tour de france avec
en toile de fond la ville qu'il
s'apprête à quitter ici on est à tour et
donc on reconnaît très très bien cette
ligne arrêtée là le long de la loire à
la avec bien évidemment la cathédrale et
donc on passe le pont de pierre et on se
retrouve au niveau de l'autre rive avec
la barrière d'octroi l'actuelle place
choiseul sur laquelle se faisait
effectivement ce rituel de départ des
trésors comme celui là le musée
tourangeaux en possède une vingtaine des
pièces exceptionnelles qu'il faut à tout
prix préserver et il y a urgence
plusieurs d'entre elles ont subi les
outrages du temps
mais pas seulement on a d'autres pièces
sur lesquelles on a des dégradations
plus importantes attaques d'insectes
notamment on peut également avoir eu des
déchirures des auréoles andy liées à
l'humidité voire parfois un peu de
moisissures donc c'est tout c'est c'est
toutes ces dégradations qu'on doit
traiter dans le cadre de cette campagne
pour sauver cette collection la plus
importante de france
une campagne de financement participatif
a été lancée sur internet
objectif atteindre vingt mille euros de
dons avec en guise de remerciements
quelques contreparties tous les
donateurs auront leur nom qui sera
affichée s'ils n'ont pas souhaité garder
l'anonymat donc pendant l'exposition qui
exposera ses
ces conduites restaurer on a également
prévu des temps un petit peu privilégiés
avec les restaurateurs avec la pour
l'équipe de conservation du musée pour
vraiment rentrés au coeur du projet pour
participer à ce vaste chantier de
rénovation
rendez vous sur le site de la fondation
du patrimoine
les dons serviront également à financer
la numérisation des oeuvres de quoi
assurer l'avenir de ses morceaux
d'histoire